megan et harry donc on en parle pour de
vrai c'est la dernière sortie officielle
et on a vraiment peu plus dur chaude
entre les deux frères enfin bref qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'était leur tournée
d'adieu en angleterre donc ils sont
repartis maintenant au canada on ne les
verra plus c'était la première fois
qu'on les voyait depuis huit mois
ensemble la reine charles way bref tout
et surtout kate et william et mégane et
harry lundi dernier à l'abbaye de
wesminster nice vous avez labs et l'ours
et france 2 regardez alors regardez à la
voilà donc vous avez vous avez harry
alors vous avez mega mega d anvers et
kate en rouge n'y a pas un regard
regarder le protocole veut que ce soit
d'abord harry et mégane qui rentre parce
que voilà hop
regardez à richard gray abord parce que
ces protocoles ils sont derrière donc on
avait revêtu dans le dernier la dernière
arrivée c'est la reine regardez ya pas
regarder ils se disent bonjour api dit
bonjour
regardez elle un regard figé arrivée
regarder harry dit bonjour et regarder
petit frère le grand frère william
il lui dit de beaux jours de loin
regardez quête pas un regard charles
arrive avec sa femme
charles il est très sympathique avec son
fils harry bonjour mon fils comment tu
vas la femme de kate regarder et ça
c'est la sortie
regardez la tête de harry il est
totalement figée vous allez avoir la
vraie sortie de la cathédrale ans fait
face de l'abbaye ensuite puisque la
reine et devant charles ça c'est le saas
et le sait le protocole la reine
les héritiers d'abord et d'aucun élément
clair l'autre et en vert pomme l'autre
en rouge pomme c'est obligatoire les
couleurs oui alors c'est le protocole
anglais alors je vous donne juste un
petit détail quand la reine et de sortie
et la famille royale est sorti la reine
prévient par parme l ai dit je serai en
bleu et selon le protocole ont choisi la
couleur donc c'est d'abord quête qui
choisit sa couleur est ensuite souvent
c'est pas ça que les cousins éloignés
sur angry voyez par exemple derrière là
blanc c'est le fils de la reine il est
dernier au pot de colle alors la pauvre
femme belle et en blanc il est on est
d'accord que la femme de l espace
d'abord de balados milian pardon de
william sheller d'abord elle la couleur
qu'elle va porter avant mais c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont dans cet ordre là et là
elle est en rouge megal et ça a beaucoup
plus anglais pardon kate est en rouge
elle a recyclé une tenue qu'elle avait à
noël 2018 alors que megan pour sa tôt
pour sa tournée d'adieu alors elle l a
fait péter la mède
il lui jamie dans tous les sens alors
allé en manolo baalbeck blahnik enfin
bref des couturiers très très cher et ça
n'a pas vraiment plu aux angles d'accord
les anglais en mêlée mais le côté
effectivement on économise un petit peu
et on est d'accord aussi que j'ai lu
aussi que la couleur est beaucoup plus
flashy c'est bête tout ça mais pour
voilà pour qu'on la remarque plus et une
fois encore l effet d'effacer les deux
autres essais la tour des films entre
les yeux cette fille là c'est du sien
dans sa poussette et fouquet en tout cas
bravo et donc on est d'accord que le bal
le pain on vous a posé avec leurs
tunnels chez vous aussi
le divorce est il consommé notamment
entre les deux frères il ya beaucoup de
oui beaucoup de noms alors tu essaies
père tristan soir alors oui voilà du
clash mais non mes deux frères qui se
fâchent comme ça alors qu'ils étaient
soudés depuis toujours se marre mais
quand même hyper triste et quelque part
à l'ats c'est vraiment week-end faisant
parler toujours très mal de magen les
mégane mais c'est quand même ce qu'elle
a fait pire c'est vraiment bien avant
lui qui ne fait pas vraiment et
travailler un sommet entendaient rester
soudés quoi oui je la princesse dire que
j'ai dit non non mais la princesse diana
avait averti en tout cas ses fils de
rester soudé parce qu'il y allait avoir
des moments très difficiles
elle l'avait peut-être pressenti je sais
pas mais c'était quelque chose en tout
cas laure mouchot de l'est parce que ça
reviendra ça reste ça
enfin alors mejia mais après c'est bien
mais ce qui est assez horrible c'est que
williams était arrivé un peu plus tôt en
angleterre avant mégane justement pour
pouvoir pendant oui oui pour pouvoir
parler à son frère est en fait les
agendas non pas coïncider enfin ils ont
pas voulu faire coïncider courage à ce
qui fait qu'en fait ils n'ont pas pu
vraiment se parler donc ça c'est évident
et au même endroit à bari bibé longtemps
acquis à kingston palace avant de se
marier avec megan la chine essaie de
rentrer de mec oui mathieu et puis après
celle qui a des infos aussi il faut un
peu comprendre
will i am en fait à harry a fait
exploser complètement le protocole et
les codes moyens truc qui me
m'interpelle sur les images qu'on a vu
c'est le regard du prince charles avec
une question que je pose est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un fils préféré dans l'histoire
qui ne serait pas justement le plus
fragile est-ce que c'est pas ça un peu
où je ressens quelque chose comme ça il
ya un truc non mais il servait il l'a
pas vu depuis longtemps c'est juste
qu'il avait mimé charles a eu une
jeunesse très compliqué je si les gens
suivent de caunes qui me fait rire
génial sur les flics regarder l'histoire
cette famille le principe peut se
reconnaître justement son fils le plus
fragile bon en tout cas moi je note
aussi quand même que le petit à petit
dans tout ça c'est celui qui qui le
payent le plus parce qu'il lui restait
au canada c'est ça assène abbaoui à lui
donc j'ai eu juste pour rebondir avant
tout mes confrères là bas maintenant on
les appelle les frères ennemis
ah oui bah oui oui parce que pour eux
vraiment qu'ils observent et qui voient
ils m'avaient les infos savent que le
divorce est consommé
concernant le petit archi c'est un peu
c'est un peu grincer des dents au canada
parce que le fait qu'il soit retrouvé
tout seul au canada pendant que ses
parents étaient en angleterre il y a
fallu assurer la sécurité
ça a coûté 60 mille euros aux
contribuables canadiens
et ça commence à grincer des dents oui
mais c'est pour à cause du coup ils ont
préféré le laisser au canada
d'ailleurs la meilleure amie de mégane
qui l'a gardé jessica mulroney qui est
également sa styliste d'accord et les
60000 euros effectivement c'est pour toi
c'est que tu es noter quand même que on
a été les premiers et quasiment un an à
dire que les deux frères s'étaient
contentés sur tout ce qui se passe
maintenant on l'avait comme annoncé sauf
mais non la tête d un four dira ce qu'on
voudra mais des infos dans cette
émission et ça ça ira très bien vous
avez ses abonnés vous attend vous et
vous seuls qui a dit que le sud ont
déchiré